wer heute ein video mit lisa und lena
kleine kamera bei ge capital corp
dezember wieder klatschen ist bereits
wieder eingeblendet ich weiß noch nicht
genau wie ich das video nennen werde
ihr seht es wahrscheinlich irgendwie
schon eingeblendet wenn ihr euch
darunter noch nichts denken könnte der
damen und ich haben wir sind hier heute
zu viert sind zwei teams macht mich sind
ein team und die beiden hier sind ein
team wie heißt ihr team
[Musik]
es geht heute darum dass eine person vor
der kamera sitzt zum beispiel max und
maxi muss fragen beantworten die wir
innerhalb von einer minute stellen
werden allerdings muss maxi fragen nicht
der reihenfolge nach beantworten sondern
die erste frage kommen wartet der kurzen
dann bei der zweiten frage muss er die
herzen frage beantworten
dritte frage also die zweite frage
beantworten bei der frage die dritte
also immer die vorherige frage muss
beantwortet werden also innerhalb von
einer minute muss merkel so viele fragen
wie geht
[Applaus]
was reimt sich auf bügeleisen wie macht
der hund bügel scheiße was ist das
gegenteil von salzig wieder weil die
schwester der mutter in welcher stadt
liegt die freiheitsstatue mit dem
baumeister new york es ist hier gut und
legal malerei bob der baumeister
achtung sprichwort wenn sich zwei
streiten freut sich der wenn es regnet
dann scheint meistens nicht die dritte
und das ist die größte stadt
deutschlands sondern wie heißt der ort
an dem harry potter zauberland
[Applaus]
beliebt
was fehlt in diesem kinderlied laterne
laterne sonne mond und ich habe frage
vorbereitet ist bereit eigentlich wie
heißt das nach was 30 reflex noch mal
jeweils das handy von apple
hektisch an der front nach nutzen mit
stativ bei der wäsche farben orange ein
bügelbrett sagt einen reim auf haus wird
gerade das heißt mit nachnamen dorn im
auge der luft in der wurde immer wieder
trieb das computertechnik und wie haben
sie grüßen hier viel strom
welche fragen hat eine rose sowohl
schwarz wirst du kein zwilling ja wie
viele weide hat ein holz hin hatte das
wort begrüßte 4 ist hier gefordert
hätten
zwei fixe ändert dass das blaue ist wenn
er das alphabet blaue band faltenrock
ausspricht dann aber dfg hat keiner der
cdu wählt das macht die kuh dann ist man
tot was ergeben 360 wii 14 hast du
nachts es gegen groß sehen welche
sprache spricht mit dem vergleichen was
er ist französisch welches ja war
letztes jahr
nein wie heißt du auf instagram sweater
was essen vegetarier nicht locker auf
fleisch b senf oder zehn milchprodukte
laser luca ja es ist aber ins fleisch
welche farben hat welche fahrrad in die
schule heiko hofmann buchstabieren
traktor weiß wenn ein anderes wort für
geschäftsverkehr ttr hht wo er
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
die schüsse hätten keine andere freunde
was hier heißt das aktuelle album
welches ikone mark cristiano ronaldo
iphone iks weiß welche farbe haben meine
schuhe so wehgetan kommt nach vier weiß
wie figur ist 5 wann ist weihnachten
fünf nach zwölf im verein ist wo steht
die freiheitsstatue 24 dezember warum
ist die banane krumm new york magst du
lieber bürger kitze was ist das
wahrzeichen von kellnern
ich will die möglichkeit kopfhörer
abgesagt was haben eine frage davor
alter warum bist du ein loch hinein ja
selbst nein weil ich noch mal nach
[Musik]
das heutige wir jetzt auch beenden meine
damen und herren ihr seht hier nochmal
den punktestand eingeblendet ich bin
ganz ehrlich wir konnten uns das bei dem
herzen sondern doch nicht richtig merken
oder aufschreiben will sagen der
verlierer muss auf dem boden liegen
last leichter wenn es euch gefallen hat
schaut nicht bei den anderen vorbei typ
[Musik]
ein